let's take some phone calls we're taking
phone calls today for the last time in
2016 because this is going to be the
last uh well like I said it the last
time we're taking calls for the year we
will start first with our caller from
the 907 area code caller what's your
name and where you calling from caller
what's your name rotisserie right all
yes the hyatt my name is jeff i'm
calling and palmer alaska excellent
what's on your mind well i just wanted
to let you know that i have been really
frustrated with media mainstream me i
used to watch msn and rachel maddow and
ended up being pretty frustrated and
cutting the cord on cable and was
looking around and found young turks and
then secular talk and in the humanist
record your so david pakman and uh you
know it just opened my eyes that people
are actually uh talking about real
issues and I you know not hiding a pine
the corporate media you know and it just
is a a breath of fresh air you know I
didn't know people like you guys existed
oh yeah we exist and we are you know to
the extent that the extent that the
audience wants is to be here we will be
here and you know that's why we do
things like reviewer funded we do
fundraisers is needed for new
initiatives etcetera so absolutely thank
you so much really appreciate the kind
words and hopefully because of people
like Jeff in Alaska we will continue to
flourish and grow in 2017 thanks so much
for the call appreciate it thank you
alright very good starting off on a
positive note today guys we don't always
get a positive calls